[Music]
it was announced last night that as
Prince Harry and Megan Marko build a
life outside of the British royal family
they will drop the word royal from any
future branding during intense
negotiations with the Queen since
January the couple's plans for their
future have been significantly
restricted in TS te joins us from our
London bureau with the latest MTS good
morning Michele good morning to you
well Harry and Megan you know really
just laying bare their frustrations that
these negotiations with the palace
saying that you know it would have been
their preference had they've been able
to continue to quote a rather and I
quote here represent and support Her
Majesty the Queen and even hinting at
their regret that they just didn't get
the concessions they were hoping for
including hanging on to that very
valuable Sussex royal brand in what's
become Harry and Megan's trademark way
of communicating big announcements they
turn to their online platforms where
they clarify the terms by which they
plan to go it alone terms which follow
weeks of negotiations after the Queen
gave her blessings they could step back
but only if they made a clean break so
now they have to scrub royal from there
at Sussex Royal Instagram page with its
over 11 million followers and from their
website
Sussex royal calm were they
sensationally announced they were
stepping back from official duties
earlier this year with the couple now
waving goodbye to Sussex royal the brand
they're saying hello to well they
haven't said yet PR guru mark Borkowski
the question everybody wants to know is
by denying this title what they got to
lose I'm I feel now that most of the
world know who Megan Harry are what they
stand for I'm not sure is that important
to have the title when Harry and Megan
started plotting their paths away from
the royal family and towards financial
independence it was clear the
progressive new role they wanted to
create for themselves involved cashing
in on trademarks of Sussex royal and
Sussex Royal Foundation to use on
everything
books to socks charity campaigns to
social care it's a major hurdle has been
put in front of them because clearly the
royal family see them as a threat so
they've got to rethink again about what
their corporate brand stands for what
the name is now March 31st this is a day
set for when the couple's new life will
formally begin
but even as Harry and Megan embark on
becoming a global brand it'll all be up
for review by the palace in just a
year's time certainly we'll MTO's tie-up
we thank you what do you guys think
Dana makes a great point just if you go
by here and Megan people know that more
than that Sussex royal air right no I
think perfect I think you're right
I think they'll find you're right I
think you're right we're all right we're
perfect right Megan in an area Harry and
me